Speaker 1: So on Sunday, when I started preparing
our Monday show, I didn't realize that this would
be the week of the burner phone where burner
phones becomes a topic just about every single
day. But it is, and we have hilarious new
information about burner phones. And it
actually comes from Trump's former national
security adviser, John Bolton, who appeared
on CNN yesterday and said Trump not only used
burner phones all the time, he used the term
burner phones all the time. So let's back up and
kind of give you the genesis of this entire lie.
The first thing that happened was that we learned
that the call logs turned over to the January six
Trump Riot Committee by the Trump White House
were missing about seven and a half hours of
calls. And one of the things that was speculated
was, Well, OK, they might have just deleted the
records of what happened on the phones during
those seven and a half hours. But also, Trump
might have been using the phones of associates
during those seven and a half hours. Or he might
have been using burner phones. These disposable
phones that you use and then you throw away, OK,
Trump, first and foremost, immediately put out
a statement saying, I have no idea what a burner
phone is. To the best of my knowledge, I have
never even heard the term. And I immediately told
you that seems like an obvious lie, just doesn't
really make any sense that that's not a term
Trump would be familiar with. The next day, we got
a statement written statement from John Bolton,
Trump's former national security adviser to CBS
News. And the statement was I heard Trump used
the phrase burner phones multiple times,
and Trump absolutely knows what it means
makes perfect sense. It's just not believable that
Donald Trump doesn't know what a burner phone is.
Obviously, Trump knows and uses the term, but
it was just kind of a written statement. We now
have an interview of Donald Trump's former
national security adviser, John Bolton on CNN,
saying he used the term all the time. And you know
what? I believe John Bolton, and I'll tell you why
in a second. Take a listen to this report.
Speaker 2: The House Select Committee
investigating the Jan. six insurrection is looking
into whether former President Trump used so-called
burner phones during a seven hour gap in official
White House call records during the riot during
the attack on the Capitol. In response, Trump
said in the statement quote, I have no idea what
a burner phone is. To the best of my knowledge, I
have never even heard of of the term. Joining us
now is former Trump national security adviser
John Bolton. Sir, what do you say to that?
Speaker 5: Well, I can't understand
what the former president is saying,
because I heard him use the term burner phone
a number of times, it's hardly like in some
obscure or highly classified set of words.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's not like key bump
about cocaine, key bumps like Madison Cawthorn
use guys. Everybody knows what a burner phone is.
Speaker 5: Criminal gangs in the
United States use burner phones,
terrorist around the world, use barn burner
phones and as I say, I heard him mention it. So
you'll have to. You'll have to guess what
the reason for his statement is, he said.
Speaker 2: Quote burner phones in conversation.
Speaker 5: He did, yes, it was a term he actually
kind of liked, he'd say, you know, they
have these burner phones, so you know,
it's the president. Former president's
acquaintance with the truth is often very casual.
Speaker 1: I think Bolton's telling the truth,
guys, I mean, look at Bolton is a terrible,
warmongering Neo-Con, but he's clearly the
more trustworthy one here. First of all,
logic tells us Trump's constant logic
tells us Trump's constantly. First of all,
trying to hide records of the things that
he's doing. Is it likely that the term burner
phone has never come up in his trying to hide
records of the things that he does? Secondly,
Trump's constantly talking about gang activity
in the United States, undocumented immigrants
trafficking Ms-13, et cetera. Do whatever your
opinion is about Trump's view on immigration.
Do we really believe that the term burner phones
hasn't been regularly used in Trump's discussions
with officials about immigration and gangs
and so on? It's just not believable and as
horrible a person as John Bolton is architect
of the Iraq War. I mean, horrible, horrible guy
in this particular disagreement. It's very clear
who's telling the truth. By the way, this is kind
of funny, too. There is even a picture now that
has been found where it looks like Trump. Has a
presidential burner phone, whether there's these
pictures and we're showing one to our audience
where Trump has phones wrapped in newspapers,
when he's getting on and off the golf course,
and again, the speculation is this is a really
weird way to carry a phone that these are phones.
Trump is handed to make individual phone calls and
then they're just given back to whoever wrapped up
in the newspaper and thrown into the trash. That's
speculative. That's speculative. But there are a
number of these pictures, so why does it matter?
Well, it matters because as usual, Trump is lying
about everything down to the absolute, smallest
detail. That's why we care about it. That's why
it matters. And he's lying when it comes to hiding
his phone activity on January 6th. He's lying when
it comes to what he was doing during that time and
his motivations in his reaction, in his opinion
about what happened on January 6th. And he's
obviously lying about the little things as well.
Like burner phone. I don't know. I've never heard
of that, that that's never it's quite frankly,
it's like a cocaine user saying, I don't know what
a key bump is. I've never that's never that's not
a term I've ever heard. Come on, guys. It's just
not believable. And we are not rehabilitating John
Bolton's image. We are not doing anything
other than saying in this particular case,
it's obvious to me that Bolton's
the guy that's telling the truth.